well if Rescuers do find the submersible
they'll need different equipment to save
those on board aldazarus Colin Baker has
more on that
so one is coming from the private sector
there's a ship called Deep energy it's
owned by a French American group and
it's bringing remote controlled robots
that can do industrial tasks like
putting down cables at 3 000 meters
beneath the surface but there are other
options from the scientific Community a
French ocean Institute is sending its
ship called the atalant which carries a
device that can dive to 6 000 meters see
what's there manipulate objects in front
of it but of course the military has
options too the U.S Navy told media it's
sending its deep sea ocean Salvage
system which can lift objects from the
bottom to the surface of up to 27 tons
now it's been used to salvage aircraft
that were lost at sea but with oxygen
running out on the submersible these
systems still have to arrive at the site
and then find the missing vessel